ben affleck's batman will live on in the
multiverse twisting flash movie but matt
reeves the batman is doing something new
in a world all its own here's everything
you need to know about robert pattinson
and the batman
the batman has been in development for
so long that the bat was originally
supposed to be a totally different man
originally the batman was imagined as an
entry in the dc extended universe
working in the same world as man of
steel and batman vs superman dawn of
justice at the time it was a given that
ben affleck would be reprising the role
of bruce wayne while also serving as the
movie's writer and director once affleck
stepped down as director and a script
was shelved new director matt reeves
came on board with his own pitch for a
batman film that would call for a
younger actor in the role robert
pattinson was reeve's first choice for
bruce wayne with the filmmaker saying he
wrote the part specifically for him
pattinson is best known to the public
for his lead role in the twilight films
but in the years since those movies came
and went he's also become a critical
darling for his work in smaller films
like good time and the lighthouse
pattinson's casting was something of a
surprise for years he's avoided major
franchise projects reportedly having a
less than stellar experience with
twilight but it turns out that he like a
lot of people is a lifelong batman fan
and jumped at the chance to portray his
own version of the character pattinson's
casting in 2019 was met with a
predictable amount of fan backlash and
pattinson also stirred up a bit of
controversy when he jokingly claimed he
wouldn't be hitting the gym to beef up
for the role this kind of criticism is
nothing new and it's hard to take too
seriously remember that originally
people had doubts about heath ledger as
the joker other criticisms around his
interpretation haven't made a lot of
sense like mocking the so-called emo
black makeup around pattinson's eyes
when he removes his cowl those critics
are apparently unaware that every
live-action batman since michael keaton
has filled in the space between their
eyes and their cowl with black makeup at
least when the cowl is on unlike the
caped crusader and batman returns and
batman vs superman dawn of justice this
batman still has the makeup on when he
removes his cowl which just makes sense
one thing's for certain patinson's take
will definitely be different from what
we've seen on screen before less
charming more broken the actor told
movie maker i want to play a dirty dirty
slimy batman
soon after ben affleck walked away from
the batman directing gig news broke that
matt reeves would be taking on the task
of shepherding the batman from concept
to completion while the batman will be
reeve's first foray into the world of
superheroes he is no stranger to films
featuring high concepts and
larger-than-life characters as evidenced
by his directorial work on cloverfield
and the rebooted planet of the apes
films at first the intent was for reeves
to use ben affleck's script directing
affleck in the role but a few months
after he was brought on board as
director reeves announced that he was
tossing out affleck's screenplay and
starting from scratch while reeve's
script features a younger protagonist
than afflecks would have the director
told variety that he still hopes to
deliver a mature ambitious film that
doesn't talk down to its audience and
offers a quote epic and emotional new
take on the character
when the batman was first announced it
was intended as another chapter in the
dc extended universe pitting ben
affleck's veteran dark knight against
the assassin slade wilson aka
deathstroke to be played by joe
manganello manganello's role in the film
was teased in zack snyder's version of
justice league which showed lex luthor
revealing batman's secret identity to
deathstroke
his name
is bruce wayne
according to manganello deathstroke
would have used this information to
exact his cruel vengeance on those close
to bruce wayne and to do battle with
both batman and his teammate batgirl
this is one of the many plot threads
from zack snyder's justice league that
are now left dangling indefinitely as dc
films retools its cinematic universe
after discarding the original script for
the batman matt reeves set out to write
a news story that would stand more on
its own he said in a 2022 interview with
esquire i respect that the dc universe
has become an extended universe and all
the movies were kind of connected but
another batman film it shouldn't have to
carry the weight of connecting the
characters from all those other movies i
didn't want them in there instead the
batman would be set in its own
continuity divorced from the dceu but
fans itching for more bat fleck will
still get at least one final film
featuring his take on the character when
the flash hits theaters in november 2022
in an interview with the hollywood
reporter in 2019 reeves said that his
screenplay for the batman would be a
quote point of view driven noir batman
tale he also said it would lean into the
notion of bruce wayne as the world's
greatest detective reeves also promised
an emotional transformative arc for the
character reeves told digital spy that
he sees batman as a quote tortured soul
who is struggling to find a way to do
the right thing in a very imperfect
world as christian bale's batman
famously said and batman begins it's not
who i am underneath
but what i do
that defines me
based on reeves comments we expect his
take on the character to be more
introspective and intellectual than what
we've seen in previous films while it's
probably a safe bet that the batman will
feature its fair share of fistfights
explosions and mind-blowing back gadgets
after all this is still a dc superhero
movie don't be surprised if reeves
batman turns out to be defined by who he
is underneath after all
it was revealed early on that key
villain roles in the batman would be
filled by the penguin and catwoman after
several rounds of lively casting rumors
that included vanessa hudgins aubry
plaza lupita nyong'o tessa thompson gugu
and bata ra alexandra ship and logan
browning speculation about who will be
portraying selena kyle in the batman
finally came to an end big little lie
star zoe kravitz will be portraying the
caped crusaders iconic femme fatale in
matt reeves film selena has a rich and
complex history with bruce wayne in the
comics and her role in the film could go
any number of directions the batman
won't be kravitz's first or even second
foray into comic book fair although
it'll be her first starring role in a
superhero film she previously played the
mutant angel salvador aka tempest in
2011's x-men first class and also
provided the voice for mary jane in
2018's spider-man into the spider-verse
the most perfectly relevant gig on her
resume she's already played catwoman
once before having lent her voice to the
lego batman movie
while catwoman has rarely been depicted
as an outright villain in batman
mythology the past 30 years in
particular have seen her rise into an
anti-hero in her own right in the comics
selena kyle has led her own ongoing
comic series almost continuously since
1993 after a limited series run in 1989.
she's arguably the protagonist of 1992's
batman returns got a much mocked film of
her own in 2004 and fought alongside
batman in 2012's the dark knight rises
if the trailers are any indication the
batman will explore the character from a
few different angles as a thief as a
vigilante and as a romantic foil for
batman zoe kravitz told empire magazine
that the batman is an origin story for
selena in keeping with matt reeve's
vision of the batman as a film noir
kravitz sees selena as a femme fatale as
well as a fighter kravitz studied a mix
of different martial arts that would be
practical for a smaller leaner person to
use when taking on larger opponents
selena's severe haircut and makeshift
catwoman disguise seen in the film seem
heavily inspired by her appearance in
the famous 4 issue arc batman year 1 by
writer frank miller and artist david
matsukeli in this story selena follows
batman's example and creates a costumed
identity under which to stock the roofs
of gotham but she and batman don't have
much interaction the early flirtation
between bat and cat is explored more
fully in its spiritual sequel the long
halloween by jeff loeb and tim sale
which has been cited along with year one
as one of the inspirations for the
batman
the path the batman took from
announcement to release spanned nearly
eight years it was among the slate of 10
dc comics inspired films that warner
brothers announced way back in october
2014 before cameras had even stopped
rolling on batman vs superman dawn of
justice the matt reeves batman was
initially supposed to be released on
june 25th 2021 but this announcement was
made before the start of the covet 19
pandemic which halted production about a
quarter of the way through shooting this
pushed the release to october 1st 2021
but an outbreak of the virus on set in
september 2020 paused production for an
additional two weeks this may have
contributed to the release date being
moved yet again though it's more likely
that warner brothers simply wanted a few
more months for cases of the disease to
decline and perhaps to not have to
release the film day and date on hbo max
with the rest of their 2021 slate
shortly after the second kova delay the
batman received its third and final
release date of march 4th 2022 the film
will play exclusively in theaters for 45
days and then stream on hbo max
beginning april 19th
the batman finds bruce wayne in less
than ideal condition and we're not just
talking about those scars on his back a
year into his crime-fighting career as
batman wayne is still struggling with
some deep psychological scars and
allowing his life outside the cape and
cowl to crumble writer director matt
reeves has stated in an interview with
empire that this version of bruce wayne
is not really a socialite at all and is
letting his family home and legacy decay
reeves inspiration for the depressed
rage field bruce wayne tragic 90s rock
icon kurt cobain
according to his feature in esquire
reefs became fixated on the nirvana song
something in the way while writing the
first act of the script leading him to
imagine bruce wayne as a total recluse
struggling with addiction in his case to
violence he cites the song which was
remixed for film's first theatrical
trailer and the gus van sand film last
days which centered around a kurt cobain
type character as inspiring this take on
bruce according to pattinson his batman
is constantly battling against his own
urge to kill displacing the rage he
feels towards his parents killer on to
the other criminals of gotham being
batman is an outlet for his anger but
not necessarily a salve in short he's
not getting better
early in the development of the batman
matt reeves parried speculation that his
young batman movie would be yet another
origin story instead reeves has defined
his film as a year 2 batman tale
skipping past the well-trod territory of
batman begins and batman year 1. reeves
told esquire a lot of times you see
stories where he's already become batman
then the rogues gallery villain comes in
and it's then their story and you watch
him go toe to toe with them i wanted the
main character in this story to be a
batman who was a year in and still
trying to figure out how to do this how
to be effective and he's not necessarily
succeeding
anytime a filmmaker comes on board to
reboot the batman character for the
silver screen you'll hear the same
familiar refrain they want to take the
character back to his gritty pulpy roots
usually this means looking back at one
of two essential graphic novels of the
mid-1980s the dark knight returns and
batman year one both written by frank
miller which helped codify a more
grounded take that had been evolving for
decades in the pages of the monthly
comics matt reeves is certainly not an
exception to this year 1 is indeed one
of his favorites he's also cited jeff
loeb and tim sales 1997 miniseries the
long halloween as an inspiration in fact
at one point warner brothers animation
was told to put their own adaptation of
the long halloween story on hold because
it was being considered as the direct
source material for the batman it
wouldn't be the first time the comics
served as inspiration for batman film
either the long halloween is one of the
clearest comics influences on 2008's the
dark knight more exciting however is
reeves professed love of not only
pre-miller batman creators like bill
finger and neil adams but the 2000
graphic novel batman ego by cartoonist
darwin cook ego is a deep and visually
stunning psychological study of the dark
knight perfect inspiration for a batman
film that's intended to be richly
emotional and focused on the title
character the trailers also hint that
certain aspects of scott snyder and greg
capullo's run on the character may make
an appearance as well
character actor jeffrey wright became
the fifth man to portray gotham city
police commissioner james gordon in a
live-action feature following neil
hamilton in the 1966 continuation of the
batman television series pat hingle in
the burton and schumacher series gary
oldman in the dark knight trilogy and jk
simmons in the dc extended universe
wright is no stranger to major
franchises having played cia agent felix
lyder in three installments of the james
bond series bt and the hunger games
mockingjay and having lent his voice to
uatu the watcher in marvel's what if in
the years since his casting in the
batman geoffrey wright has also lent his
voice to the dark knight himself in
batman the audio adventures a campy
radio style drama that streams on hbo
max according to an interview with indie
wire wright was attracted to the
realistic tone of the film i saw the
themes around corruption and class
tensions and all of the things that he
wanted to bring from the outside into
this world so it had some relevance
warner brothers confirmed in october
2019 that paul dano had officially come
aboard the film as the riddler dano is
well suited for a dark and menacing
villain having been nominated for an
emmy for his work on the showtime
limited series escape at dannemora in
which he portrayed real-life convicted
murderer david sweat
dana has played a wide variety of roles
during his eclectic career from gently
comedic turns in films like swiss army
man and little miss sunshine to more
serious roles in films such as prisoners
okja and there will be blood the thread
that seems to tie all of dana's
characters together is a sense of deep
interior personality and emotional
complexity which will serve him well as
the enigmatic riddler matt reeves
casting of the soulful often somber dano
is a far cry from the rubber limbed jim
carrey who played the role in 1995's
batman forever
when matt reeves imagined his ideal
batman film it was always through the
lens of a detective story from there it
was a logical leap for the film's main
antagonist to be more of an intellectual
challenge for batman than a physical
threat hence the riddler a batman
villain famous for his puzzles and mind
games rather than fighting prowess in
the batman matt reeves has reimagined
the riddler as a serial killer in the
tradition of the zodiac killer the
real-life murderer who mailed clues
about his targets and identity to
newspapers in the late 1960s reeves told
esquire i started thinking of the zodiac
killer because he did create a costume
for himself and he wore a black hood he
had his own insignia he was an early
anti-superhero a scary figure who
terrorized california this version of
the riddler who uses his canonical birth
name from the comics edward nashton
taunts batman with written and recorded
messages and may even already be aware
of a secret identity as bruce wayne
indeed ridler seems to be directing
batman towards solving a mystery about
corruption in gotham that involves the
wayne family
without question the most surprising
casting choice in the batman is colin
farrell as oswald penguin cobblepot
cobblepot is typically portrayed as a
short ugly man with a rotund body a far
cry from colin farrell's leading man
good looks but like danny devito and to
a lesser extent gotham actor rob and
lord taylor before him farrell's
appearance has been altered via applied
prosthetics to make him a closer match
for the notorious crime boss of the
comics it took between two and four
hours to apply farrell's facial scars a
heftier neck and receding hairline those
transformation didn't stop there farrell
is practically unrecognizable in his
performance donning the type of thick
new york accent you'd hear in a scorsese
gangster film
take it easy sweetheart
or should we say coppola farrell cites
the godfather character fredo corleone
the weak-willed older brother of kingpin
michael corleone as his inspiration for
the character like fredo feral told
empire online that his oz cobblepot is
quote rippled by the insignificance that
he lives within in a family that is full
of very strong very bright very capable
very violent men it's a role he says
he'd be interested in exploring in a
sequel and he may very well get the
chance to spend more time with the
character there's a spin-off series for
the penguin in early development at hbo
max in the comics oswald comes from old
gotham money operating his criminal
empire under the very thin guys of
legitimate business he's often portrayed
as one of the only traditional gangsters
to maintain his foothold in the gotham
underworld after the rise of more
outlandish villains like the joker
two-face and black mask whether oz's
inferiority complex may come from
feeling overshadowed by his family
legacy or from the changing face of
crime in gotham in the batman we'll just
have to wait and see
the impressive cast of the batman also
includes emmy-winning character actor
john turturro who will be playing
gotham's powerful crime boss carmine
falcone sometimes nicknamed the roman
and based on marlon brando's character
from the godfather falcone first debuted
in frank miller and david matsukeli's
batman year one comics but assumed a
much more prominent role later on in
batman the long halloween in the comics
falcone effectively runs gotham city and
is determined to put a stop to batman's
vigilante actions in order to solidify
his stronghold on the city falcone has
previously been portrayed on screen by
tom wilkinson in the film batman begins
and john doman on the television series
gotham further complicating falcone's
relationship with batman in the comics
is the fact that bruce's father thomas
wayne once saved falcone's life a life
debt which falcone has sworn to someday
repay andy serkis the actor best known
for his groundbreaking cgi performance
capture roles as gollum and the lord of
the rings and caesar in the rebooted
planet of the apes trilogy will show his
actual face in the batman as alfred
pennyworth the wayne family butler who
raised the young bruce after the murder
of his parents circus becomes the fifth
actor to play alfred in a live-action
feature film following alan napier
michael goff michael kane and jeremy
irons the character has also been a
fixture on the small screen in recent
years portrayed by sean pertwee on
gotham from 2014 to 2019 and the lead
character of his own series pennyworth
starring jack bannon on hbo max circus
has plenty of history with matt reeves
who also directed dawn of the planet of
the apes and war for the planet of the
apes and reeves has apparently secured
circus a sizeable role in the batman
circus has told interviewers that the
emotional connection between alfred and
bruce is the center of the film and
trailers have hinted that the story may
hinge on some wayne family secret from
which alfred has been trying to protect
his surrogate son a larger role for
alfred in this film would be in keeping
with the way his character has been
expanded in the comics over the past few
decades from a relatively passive
participant in batman's war on crime to
an irreplaceable asset with a history as
a military medic and a secret agent of
the british government particularly
during batman's early years before the
expansion of the bat family alfred is
bruce's only friend and confidant
similarly to the way matt reeves
announced the casting for andy circus as
alfred the director took to twitter
again at the beginning of december 2019
to reveal that peter sarsgaard had
joined the cast of the batman unlike
reeve's previous few casting
announcements he didn't hashtag this
tweet with the name of the character
sarsguard will be playing instead just
sharing an animated gif sources
originally told the hollywood reporter
that the actor would either be playing a
corrupt cop named wasserman or a
district attorney leading to speculation
that he could be playing harvey dent
better known as the iconic batman
villain two phase however in early 2020
a warner brothers official press release
identified sars guard's character as
gotham d.a gil coulson a new character
who doesn't exist in the comics the
character has already made an appearance
in a promo clip being used as a hostage
by the riddler during a brazen attack on
a funeral
on february 13th 2020 matt reeves gave
us all an early valentine's day gift in
the form of a red tinted first look at
robert pattinson as the caped crusader
the 55 second camera test features
pattinson in the full bat suit and cowl
emerging from the darkness into a sharp
crimson close-up even this partial
glimpse let fans know that pattinson's
batman would have a very different look
than the dark knights that have come
before but what really sells the look
isn't any particular alchemy of
materials or cut but pattinson's
distinctive face which becomes the
ultimate focus of the short video like
ben affleck and christian bale before
him pattinson is gifted with an
authentic bruce wayne jawline cutting a
silhouette so recognizable that it makes
you really wonder why he thinks he can
get away with only covering up half his
face
on march 4th 2020 matt reeves tweeted
out the first look at the new batmobile
gone is the bulky tank-like tumbler of
christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
as well as the almost comically tricked
out stealth bomber meets fury road
version of batman's ride that ben
affleck drove in justice league for the
batman robert pattinson will be driving
a reimagined batmobile that looks like
it could have been driven straight out
of a high-end garage as opposed to a
high-tech research facility all of
batman begins this new take on bruce
wayne's iconic transport leans much more
toward a classic muscle car than its
more military-inspired predecessors
calling to mind well-known models like
the 1970 dodge challenger and the
pontiac gto since the batman is supposed
to take place early on in bruce's tenure
as the caped crusader it's easy to
believe that this version of the
batmobile represents one of the
billionaire vigilante's first attempts
at a superhero car in which he modified
something he already owned rather than
building something new the latest
version of the batmobile comes with a
before it's time in-dash video display a
sleek black custom design and an
absolute monster of an engine
the batman is deliberately isolated from
the dc extended universe where most of
dc's films take place and is intended to
stand alone it neither relies on context
from previous film incarnations of
batman nor does it prioritize setting up
sequels and spin-offs star robert
pattinson seemed to imply to total film
after seeing the finished cut that he
had a hard time imagining the movie
leading to a full film series even
though he admits it probably will as he
put it it's a really really unusual
batman story and it almost seems harder
for me to imagine it being a series
afterwards i mean they always have that
little bit at the end that's like and
coming up but other than that it feels
strangely personal i think people will
be quite shocked at how different it is
at the same time it's been reported that
warner brothers is chomping at the bit
to spin the batman into a shared
universe of films and television shows
having already put two hbo max series
into development ahead of the film's
release one would center around the
gotham city police department while
another would focus on colin farrell's
penguin this cross-platform batman
universe would have to co-exist
alongside a few other live-action
projects set in their own continuities
but this is nothing new the hbo max
series titans and the cw's batwoman both
feature a number of batman characters
take place on different earths in the dc
multiverse each show even has its own
bruce wayne played by ian glenn and
warren christie respectively though both
series avoid showing batman in costume
and then of course there's the dc
extended universe of films which in 2022
alone will feature both the ben affleck
and michael keaton incarnations of
batman but even though batman as a
character is going multiversal on the
big screen it looks like the batman is
set to stand alone check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you